hey guys came here was another GS news
update for you new doubts have been cast
over the free playstation plus edition
of drive club after the head of
playstation europe was unable to answer
questions on whether the game would
still materialize jim ryan who manages
sony computer entertainment europe was
asked in an interview with british
newspaper Metro whether the release of
the free version which was first
promised in june 2013 was still part of
sony's plans that's still being looked
at he replied when asked whether the
free version would ever ship Ryan
replied I can't say anything at this
stage gamespot has contacted Sony for
further clarification the promise was
first made way back in III 2013 when the
company made a pledge that PlayStation
Plus subscribers would be given a free
abridged version of driveclub as a
reward for their membership who doesn't
love free stuff but it's been a far from
smooth freshly tarmac road for drive
club since then hitting a number of
bumps along the way first in October
2013 when the racing sim was delayed
just weeks ahead of his launch it was
delayed again in early 2014 and when it
finally released in october it launched
with major server issues that knocked
its network infrastructure offline it
was during this troubled launch that a
decision was made at sony to postpone
the free version likely in order to
prevent the online problems worsening in
his interview with Metro Ryan wanted to
explain that Sony had worked intensively
the salvage driveclub disastrous online
launch he stressed that people were
working twenty-four/seven a maximum
expression that's lightly used but
people were working twenty-four/seven
trying to fix this now should the game
of worked at launch of course should
people pay 50 pounds for something and
expect it to work of course so were you
looking forward to getting your mitts on
free driveclub does this make you
skeptical about future promised freebies
for PlayStation Plus let me know in the
comments down below and for all other
news come on back to gamespot
you